You really have to see this. We
heard from the president yesterday.
Donald Trump published a completely deranged
and bizarre forty six minute video to Facebook
after another week went by without seeing him,
except on the golf course, continuing to promote
laughable and even conflicting conspiracy theories
about the election. This was promoted as being
maybe the most important speech ever from the
president, and they were merely the rantings of
a madman who cannot accept that he simply lost
an election. So I want to go because we have
so much to talk about today. I want to go right
into one of the most. Cartoonish moments of this
speech, which is Trump holding up of this
blown up chart of the vote count in Wisconsin,
where, as predicted, early voting was more
leaning Trump because of in-person I'm sorry,
early is a confusing term. In-person voting led
to early numbers that looked better for Trump.
And then as the mail in ballots were counted as
expected, it shifted more in the direction of Joe
Biden. So Trump now going back a month. Trump
still thinks he has something here to the vote
count sequelae in Wisconsin. Listen to this.
That Wisconsin we're leading by a lot.
And then. At three forty two in the morning,
there was this it was a massive dump of votes.
Mostly Biden, almost all Biden. And to
this day, everyone's trying to figure out
where did it come from? But I went from
leading by a lot. To losing by a little
and that's right here, that's a three.
Forty two in the morning, that's Wisconsin.
A terrible thing, there is just so
much here that is wrong, much of it,
I'm sure you can tell right away. One of
the things that is happening frequently is
they keep talking about the times of day when
votes were counted as part of the suspicion.
This happened at three forty two in the morning.
Well, it's election night and they're counting
ballots. Now, what you have to understand, this
is one of those indefeasible talking points
in other states when they stopped counting.
That was also suspicious. So really
understand the absurdity here. In some states,
they have rules like Pennsylvania was one such
state where they stopped counting for the night
on election night. At some point, it might have
been 10:00 or 11:00 p.m. Eastern in Pennsylvania.
And you had people saying that's suspicious, Dave
Rubin saying what they needed naps or something
really weird that all of a sudden they just stop
counting for the night. That was suspicious here
in Wisconsin. It's suspicious that they were still
counting at three forty two in the morning. It's
an indefeasible argument. You can't overturn the
argument. You can't combat the argument because
both sides are evidence of the same conspiracy.
Stopping the count is strange. Counting at three
a.m.. Also strange, Trump then continues and says
the election was rigged and everybody knows it.
This election was rigged. Everybody knows it.
I don't mind if I lose an election, but I want
to lose an election fair and square. What I don't
want to do is have it stolen from the American
people. That's what we're fighting for. And we
have no choice to be doing that. We already
have the proof. We already have the evidence.
And it's very clear many people in the media and
even judges so far have refused to accept it.
Now, this is really Orwellian double speak
where everything is backwards, everything is the
opposite. Trump says the judges in the media won't
accept it. Judges looked at the so-called evidence
and determined it was without merit. So they threw
out cases the media did, except that Joe Biden
won. So it's a completely backwards alternate
reality. Let's look at a little bit more.
They know it's true. They know it's there. They
know who won the election, but they refuse to say
you're right. Our country needs
somebody to say you're right.
So once again, this is this
is projection. Trump knows
it's true that Joe Biden won and it's childish
to keep pretending otherwise will continue.
Ultimately, I am prepared to accept
any accurate election result. And
I hope that Joe Biden is as well.
This is part of the continued play
to make it seem as though there is a doubt about
the result. Joe Biden and the media and most
of the American people have accepted the real
results. And it's Trump and his followers that
haven't accepted the results. It's it's all just
backwards. And then again, Trump brings up this
idea of proof, but we already have the proof.
We already have tens of thousands of ballots
more than we need. To overturn all of
these states that we're talking about,
this is an election for the highest office in
the greatest country in the history of the world,
every reasonable American should be able to
agree based on what we have already documented,
that we need a systematic analysis of the
mail in ballots to review the envelopes.
Now, this is sort of a Gish Gallop. We have
tens of thousands of examples from all over the
country. That's not how we do it. We look at one
by one judges in various states, look at examples
from those states and they look at the examples
and make a determination about their merits. And
in each individual instance, there was no merit.
This is a common debating technique. And Trump
is doing Jaeschke ballot by ballot for lack of a
better term, saying we have tens of thousands of
examples in all these different states. That's not
how we analyze it. We look at these individually
and individually. They have been found to be
without merit. Just a little more video here.
This is the absolute minimum we should
expect. This is not just about my campaign,
although it has a lot to do with
who's going to be your next president.
This is about restoring faith and
confidence in American elections.
The party that has been trying to suppress the
vote for a decade now says we need to restore
confidence. Donald Trump's attorney general,
William Barr, one of the most biased partizan
attorneys general that I can remember, already
said as of right now, there is no proof of fraud.
Trump's cybersecurity director said there
is no proof of fraud. Trump fired him.
If you really want to deal with this issue,
they have to look at their own party,
the voter purges, the attempts to kneecap the
United States Postal Service, gerrymandering
that's within the state level. They are the
ones that have actually been the perpetrators
of what they now claim they are the victims of.
It's truly a deranged speech from the president
of the United States. It is a massive historical
significance in the sense that at some point when
this is all over and the historians and the
sociologists and the psychologists and the
economists and the I mean, this is going to be
fodder for so many disciplines for a very long
time. This is exactly the type of speech that you
would look at to sort of epitomize the absolute
insanity of what we're experiencing right now.
How much longer do you think these types of
narratives from Trump will continue?
Let me know on Twitter where you can
find me at the department The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.